the right livelihood award is sometimes
dubbed the alternative Nobel Prize each
year the award honors activists and
organizations working to make the world
a better place one of this year's
winners is a Ukrainian woman who
documents war crimes and human rights
violations
Alexandra matvichuk is one of Ukraine's
most prominent human rights Defenders
and chairs the center for civil
liberties
jurors said both she and the
organization Have Been instrumental in
quote building sustainable Democratic
institutions in Ukraine modeling a path
to International accountability for war
crimes
it's the first time the right livelihood
award has gone to someone from Ukraine
and I'm joined Now by Alexander
matvichuk in Kiev thank you very much
for taking time to be with us now you
recently investigated Mass Graves
uncovered in itsyom that's a town that
was occupied by the Russian troops most
of the Dead there were civilians were
you surprised by what you found there
unfortunately we have no surprise but we
still couldn't be indifferent and to get
used to such a level of atrocities we
observed the same which we see for
example in April in Kiev region when
Russian groups were retreated from there
we also found Mass Grace and killed
civilians
do you think that war crimes and human
rights abuses are being perpetrated
systematically as a weapon of war in
Ukraine
was the seven months of Russian
large-skill aggression only our joint
initiative Tribunal for Putin have been
documented more than 19
000 episodes of world crimes and it
shows us that it's systematic and
large-scale character and Russia uses
war crimes at the method of warfare
now Russia also says that Ukraine is
perpetrating war crimes as well uh have
you seen evidence of that
we have been documenting war crimes for
eight years and we as a human rights
Defenders are defended human rights
regardless of site and if Ukrainian side
committed war crimes we also documented
them but here we have a tool how to push
for Effective investigation when we
speak about Russia there is no
possibility to stop this atrocities or
to hold perpetrators to accountability
what are the biggest challenges you face
in documenting the war in Ukraine
I'm a human rights lawyer who have been
spent 20 years protecting human rights
in Ukraine University region and last
eight years I have been documenting war
crimes and uh interviewed more than
hundreds of people who survived from
captivity and they told me horrible
horrible stories how they were beaten
how they were raped how they were like a
tortured with electricity and other ways
but even me professional human rights
lawyer wasn't prepared for such level of
atrocities sometimes I feel my that I am
working with a human thing like pure
human pain
now you've just won an award for
charting a path toward International
accountability for suspected war crimes
in Ukraine do you believe those
responsible will actually someday be
brought to Justice
we are people who not predict future
where people who create such future
which we want to see and in future for
we are struggling for is future of his
Justice So I myself and my colleagues
will do our best to hold Russian
perpetrators accountable
Alexandra matrichuk human rights lawyer
and head of the non-profit organization
Center for civil liberties thank you
very much for talking with us